the line that everybody is led to
believe but there is doctor if I if I
left you now and ran up and down
Leicester Square for 3 hours and then
went home and had a piece of lettuce and
then came in and did the same tomorrow
and the day after that and the day after
that I would start to look like a
supermodel uh only for a few months and
then you would stop in fact you would
start regaining weight within the first
year even if you only ate letters and
ran around letter Square for 3 hours
that is a fact that's not fiction are
you delusional do do you suffer from a
mental illness that is a absolute fact
even if you took that skinny jab that's
out on the market now you'd still end up
I think it's called OIC is OIC you would
end up gaining the weight that is how
the body works the body will always
return you to your natural set point
weight yeah but don't you couldn't your
natural state be like a thin one this
donut goes by the name the fat doctor
and says that she's a fat this why I say
you can get like a study to literally
say anything literally huh